good afternoon everyone
sure you know on youtube okay lovely
thank you much good afternoon ladies
gentlemen members of the committee
uh welcome to the harbour board meeting
on thursday the 24th of june
at half past two in the afternoon i
would go straight in
uh well just in four months i'm the vice
chair and i will be acting today
on behalf of councillor hicks who is
giving his apologies
so uh can we move to item one please on
agenda apologies for absence please
yes chair it's uh councillor hicks and
mr hardaker
okay
item number two on the agenda i go
through page by page
and that's the confirmation of the
minutes held on the 18th of march
2021 so page three
four five
six seven
eight nine
ten do i have a propose of those minutes
please
or any questions on this i'll propose
for a second either way
okay the post counselor james do i have
a second
time yeah christy raised his hand
yeah so i i've only got the column on
the right hand side i just see
four people on it okay yeah councillor
christie raised his hand okay
uh councillor christie over to you
please we seconded it
lovely okay okay right forwarded um
propose seconded all those in favor
i'll take the vote yeah so councillor
christie
for mr gibbs
[Applause]
oh you're muted mr gibbs
um there we go
thank you councillor james paul
councillor mcgoff
uh i love staying cause i wasn't the
president of the last meeting okay
that's three four one obstacle
okay lovely thank you much um move on to
item number three which is the
action list on page 11. um i'll just go
by the minute numbers on the left-hand
columns
uh councillors members public so it
minute number eight
yeah okay you're up on screen brilliant
all right so you can see that project in
obeyance
uh any questions on that item number 37
okay aussie hicks is in um miss kansas
is dealing with that one there
64. um ken would you be a dancer at 64
because
did you receive an email from the
harbour master
okay so i don't know um sorry
ken's no i don't think i have sorry
okay no problem so we're just we're just
following an air up then
okay if we go to number 64
um i've got a confirmation that one has
been completed
and stacy could you confirm that for us
please
it has um i've emailed councillor hicks
i think last week or the week before i
can afford it talk all committee members
um but but in short yes uh planning
application
um the planning application did receive
i'm sorry i'll start again the planning
application did uh contain an
application for the pontoon
um but there's been no discussions
between torridge
or and the developer as to who would
take on responsibility
but torridge would be reluctant to take
on responsibility for the pontoon
and should it be developed and going
forward
okay lovely thank you very much stacey
all the members happy without to
receive the invasion from stacey
yep okay okay um actually number four
is public contributions tom do we have
any members of public wishing to speak
no we don't chair okay i'll move on to
item number five
the agreement for gender items part one
and part two
um counselors we do have a one part two
item and that's item 13.
so when we get down to that point we'll
do the normal procedure okay
yep check let me just take a vote to see
if we'd like to go into part two
so do we propose that we have the
agreement yes
okay i propose get our second it can
okay counselor christy
mr gibbs counselor james
councilman goff four unanimous chair
okay item number six is
urgent matters of information brought
forward with permission of the chairman
and the committee do we have anything i
don't have nothing
um anyone else no
no nothing in the nothing background
from kenzo hicks
no i did uh speak to his staff yesterday
but
he he wasn't responding okay no
all right get done from that movement
item number seven and please it's the
non-elected members pages 12 to 13.
uh thank you chair um is it possible
that we could move item number
nine uh before the non-elected because
i've got mr paul brown
here who is the interim harbour master
and he's also the bit of a
torn tourist pilot and he has a uh
sandbarge to bring into holland and wolf
um would that be possible to bring item
nine to the front so that he can get off
yes yes uh miss hasta i propose we
suspend standing orders and
move forward number nine to item seven
so obviously
we just heard then from mr haystad the
other instrument master can actually get
on to his job
um do we need to vote for that yeah
we can just do that can't we just do
that
yes the chair can agree that i believe
okay love it right
hopefully mr brown i'll
i'll pass you over to mr paul brown
lovely to introduce himself and prevent
the
activity good afternoon chair ladies and
gentlemen
um uh my name is paul brown um i've been
the
tour and torridge uh pilot for the last
since 2017
uh i've been assisting uh captain
lavistal with hi uh
with harper with the harbour market i've
been burning for
for that time uh since um paul
reported sick um mr haste asked me to
stand in
and i think we've been doing this uh
i've been doing it for
three three three weeks now um my
my day job is i'm a marine and risk
consultant for um
uh marine risks i i obviously also pilot
and i run my water sports company in
torquay so much as i'd like to have
dropped everything in common
taking up residence in biddeford um i'm
unable to do that so we've agreed that i
will provide administration a distant
administration cover with
um one of the um mrs taylor from the
office who who
is actually on site in the harbor office
three days a week
um and so any questions uh that arise
from
though from her presence there indeed
has an email clapping
i've been dealing with and so far uh i
think hopefully mr hayes hasn't said
anything
to the contrary and so far the
arrangement appears to be working
reasonably well just for background
previously i was the
harvard master at the port of dover for
five years
before i then stepped off the um uh
that particular treadmill and came and
came and lived in god's own
county um in terms of the courted report
this this
this quarter has actually been
relatively busy um
we've had two visits from the same um
clay ship
the celtic forester once on the 12th of
march once on the 25th of may
uh on both occasions she arrived was
alongside for
less than 48 hours and then sailed again
with
uh just under 3 000 tons of uh finest
north devon
ball clay bound for catalon in northeast
spain
um of note the after the sad party of
mike
pryor our longest long-term crane driver
who
appeared to do it just because he purely
loved it um
the now commercial arrangement with um
with an ukraine provision uh the name of
which forgets me uh
lose me the name of the the people who
provide the crane diver seems to be
working quite well
um so biddeford we've had two ships uh
which is uh in a quarter which is
um a pleasant change uh yellend um the
deo gloria
has been he came and went for her
two-week two-week
um dredge campaign which she does
normally each um
april or may um because it
that she had two masters who have their
own pilot exemption certificates
um she didn't actually require any any
input from us except for
i went out for on the first trip to
welcome them back and make sure they all
remembered
where everything was um but they came
and went uh
in may of baker partner in april and the
fresh spring
um undocked from the uh from the harlem
wall shipyard and went back to her birth
and we escorted her back up there with
the pilot vessel
in terms of what i've been doing in the
last three or four weeks
is um trying to just get my feet under
the table
in terms of where paul lavissau was um
we've been dealing with the uh uk border
force
and customs and excise as they've been
waking up from the um
into the postcovid world um and they've
obviously worked their way to all the
larger ports
now got down to us a bit to find out
um find out what it is that we do here
um and whether they need whether they
need to be worried um
and so that dialogue is ongoing i think
um um
i don't think border force actually knew
that we actually had any trade coming
out of here at all but there we go
um and the other thing that's kind of at
the top of my um
entry at the moment is the rex abandoned
metal vessels and mooring policy which
i'm
with mr hayes and i are working through
to see if we can't
update that and help um uh clarify
the situation of the harbor authority
when it comes to
looking at some of the vessels uh in the
in the harbor
authority area um other than that
so far i think the arrangement appears
to be working uh
reasonably well um and uh i look forward
to speaking to you
next quarter lovely thank you very much
uh mr brown obviously counselors this
is just been noted but if there's any
questions
would you like to raise them quickly
because obviously demand
any questions if not we should move on
yeah mr gibbs would like to ask a
question
sorry mr gibbs i can't see you on the
screen get over to you sir
um it's more than a question it's more
of a statement
i was a bit disappointed a lot
disappointed that i was
that i didn't hear officially about um
the harbour masters in this imposition
um excuse me mr gibbs um this is
something we will be discussing in part
two
if you don't mind lisa okay obviously um
quite sensitive and we're live on
youtube so i'd like to discuss our parts
thank you okay mr brown
any more questions from accountants
please
no okay right i've obviously proposed we
go back into standing orders and we
where we left off at item number seven
which really
non-elected members pages 12 to 13.
thank you chair members of the committee
so this
um brief um report
is uh to get initial approval from the
harbour board
to reappoint to the two non-elected
representatives
who are on the harbour board working
group um
the current two non-elected mr gibbs and
mr hardaker
uh their current term has expired
and they both indicated that they would
like to continue on the harbour board
working group
of which both i and the chair are very
pleased
um if members of this working group
agree that
that then it will go to full council for
final approval which is where
all non-elected members have to get
final
sign off so it's a very brief one um and
the recommendation is that members
approve the reappointment of mr tim
gibbs and mr hardaker
as non-elective representatives on the
club of the harbour board working group
thank you chad hey thank you much mr
gibbs
over to you sir uh i would make a
suggestion
that the we should consider increasing
the number of uh
independent members to try and increase
the marine exp
the relevant marine experience on the
harbour board
okay i'm skipping lucky we've got
councillor james here they needed a
council
council james can i put your spot
because we have been trying to go to
out to public
yeah thank you chair i was i was going
to just raise um you know do we do
anything to
attract more people um and you know i'm
not sure
what the constitution says in that
respect are we limited
to how many we have or can we you know
look
to increase the number stacey do you
know
sorry that's right thank you council
james um
historically and we've had um problems
recruiting independent persons
um basically um put another
out and i was pleased to say that we've
um
again subject to full council's approval
um successfully
recruited to the standards committee
we're short in quite a few areas
including
um the scrutiny committees so i've been
chatting with
the ones that have applied for standards
and they are interested in the scrutiny
role
um but certainly i mean if we had
um interest or if we didn't we were
lacking we could specifically
um put an advert out um for some
independent people for harbor
and we're always very um you know would
be very keen and very interested
um because i think it's really important
and i think you know members recognize
that as well
so subject to full council approving the
appointments
that there's no difficulty in terms of
independent persons
right uh chair could i suggest then that
we
if we've got two volunteers we don't
lose them so i propose the
recommendation
with the addition that we continue to
look for
additional members to the harbour board
yeah okay council james obviously i i
would second that uh cash change i'd
like to add on
obviously to extend my thanks out to mr
gibbs mr hardacre
obviously continue to carry on the road
but mr gates before i come to you i've
got mr puddy who's got his hand up mr
buddy over to you please demonstrate
yes thank you very much i i'm what i was
going to say is i have applied
to join the harbour committee in the
past as a as an independent member
i am now um involved in the harbour
committee through the um
biddeford bay chamber of commerce and i
would like to be considered
um as a suitable person to join the
board
in a formal capacity um i mean i have
been a ship operator i've been a ship
owner
i'm conversant with maritime regulations
um i was a member of the bristol harbour
board for many years i'm involved in
tourism um
obviously the lundy agent for many years
um
shipyard operations and i'm chair of the
apple door maritime heritage
trust and the steamship fresh fresh
spring society which is a registered
charity
so if um appropriate i would really be
pleased to be considered to joining the
board formally
okay um stacy can i just bring in that
juncture please it would it be
some correspondence you could have a mr
buddy after meeting
yes certainly chair mr buddy can you
could you send me an email
um that the protocol is uh make an
application and then
it's an interview with the chief exec
generally um and the the chair and vice
chair
and and the leader as well um should the
leader want to do that so
you send me full details i'm sure that
we we we can arrange that and then
subject to um approval we can put that
to full council
right thank you very much lovely mr
gibbs over to you
i would say to the side that uh
ilfrakkum has had no trouble
uh recruiting quite a few independent
members
so yeah i think there should be a put
there should be a
poor suitable knowledge in the area
no thank you sir we we're taking on we
noticed your comments
we're trying that for that and mr buddy
thank you very much for your offer
and we leave that to stacy so we've had
a proposal we've had a second uh
can we go to the vote please tom yeah
let's find chase councillor christy
mr gibbs paul councillor james
council mcguff actually known as chair
okay thank you okay we move on to item
number eight
which is page 14 the port and harbor
accounts
and receive the report from the
operational service manager over to you
please
thank you chair um obviously this is end
of year
um report for the harbour and pilotage
um but it's not does not exclude um
it excludes notional charges such as
central recharges
um so this is basically our operating
costs
um without as they class the
depreciation of the facilities that we
have because that should not go back to
the taxpayer
so the first part is harbours which
you've all you've all got
the the spreadsheet in front of you and
that you can see
so while we are slightly
over today on um actually the running of
the harbour has been somewhat a
different year and that
is uh in different year and that has
also been built up with the additional
um additional traffic that we've had
which is good on one hand but obviously
it costs to maintain and manage
the other part which we've done is the
heart
which is the pilotage and once again
that has proved very well in in the fact
that it's coming under a budget
um but as you can see the total cost
down
is similar to what it has been um
from uh the year before this year
going forward obviously on the budget
that i've set
which was set last november we've had
significant changes in
in personnel within the harbour
and those budgets will reflect that
uh with the expenditure um throughout
quarters one two and three before we get
to this time next year
so happy to take any questions um
back to you joe okay uh counselors
and non-elected members any questions
for mr haste
okay mr buddy yeah just one question i
mean
it may uh have already been considered
but um
in the harvard ilfracombe the uh parking
in the designated harbor area the
revenue from that parking actually goes
to the harbour authority
um i'm wondering if that could be
considered in biddeford for the actual
keysight parking
to to support the revenue for the harbor
mr hase can you answer that one yes i
think uh
members that have been on the the
harbour board for a number of years this
has been discussed
on many occasions ultimately um
the funds will go back to torres
district council um
obviously so it all goes back to the
same pot
um and therefore i don't think there's
any
any intention i think from members uh
case of james's leader may be able to
assist that
that it would necessarily look to go
back into the harbour
um and what benefit that would
necessarily have
without a business plan already put
forward
all right chair yes against james
yeah just as richard said we have
discussed it before
and it was it was a bit of pain peter so
much paul
um uh whilst we could make the
harborough cones look better
than we would probably just end up with
the car parking looking down
um so as you said it goes back to the
same part
i i can certainly see some element in it
because when the boats are in obviously
the car park are losing money to some
extent
um but at the moment i believe we
decided we would leave that as it was
okay okay thank you very much and
is this to be voted on or just know this
to be noted just for noting yes okay
counselor is very happy with that just
to note that any more questions
i'm happy to know okay lovely obviously
my item nine's already been dealt with
item 10 would be the fresh spring bond
pages
18 to 34 and mr hayes over to you again
please
okay thank you chair thank you members
um
this report while lengthy was uh quite a
few uh
quite a bit of background information um
a request of them has been made by mr
john buddy who is the chairman of the
fresh springs trust
for the bond to be returned back to the
trust um that was initially required
some five years ago
when the ss fresh spring applied to come
into
to the harbour now as you can see the
fresh spring has had
considerable significant work happening
to it
since since it came in into hopefully
what the trust believe is to return it
back to
operational use um
and initially the the bond was required
because as a condition five years ago of
the fresh spring was
not as it is now therefore the reason
for that bond was the fact that if it
were the trust were not to continue to
um
improve it or do as they would say then
it was to mitigate the risk of
it turning into a wreck into the heart
which was in the harvard jurisdiction
and therefore to release some of the
financial burden that would be put upon
torres district council um in removing
it from the harbour
jurisdiction now initially like
the bond was for nine thousand pounds um
of which
was going to be paid three thousand per
year over three years
the first three thousand was paid um and
the rest
wasn't either collected or or paid
through
um and mr puddy's requested uh so that
the
three thousand pound could go back to
the trust so that they could further
improve
and work on on the fresh spring
supporting information you've got mr
puddy's letter
uh about the trust and what has happened
and the wider benefits
of the spread and the fresh spring and
the other one is the
the second appendage to is the bonds
that the fresh spring trust
have um signed along the torres district
council
so it's basically form for members to
agree or to disagree
or to refuse sorry whether the bond
should be returned
to the fresh spring trust and
the decision that members have to make
on this committee are that you know
if we remove the bonds and while very
unlikely
the fresh spring were to fall into
disrepair
um the harbour board would have to brunt
and well the torres straits would have
to run the full cost of removal
another condition that uh that i for
members to
to discuss and decide upon is that if
the
bonds were to be returned or three
thousand pounds
that we torres district council on the
harbour board will request
annual up annual updates from the trust
in agreement with uh the um harbour
master
at that time um to undertake an annual
order and therefore if the
any work was required to be undertaken
that um and it wasn't done within a
timely fashion that
the the bond could be reinstated if the
ship were to remain in the harbor
so the recommendation is that the bond
be returned to the fresh green trust
with annual inspections and surveys
undertaken by the trust
and the harbour master to ensure that
the vessel does not deter it deteriorate
which would be a detriment to the
harbour
area thank you chad
i'm going to go to christie you had your
hand at first thank you yeah well i'd
move this
if only because it came about when we
had a
really bad experience with um another
vessel
and uh i think the harbour board were
well we were alerted to what might
happen again
um the fresh spring clearly has
brought a lot of uh visitors to benefit
also a lot of money has been spent on it
and i would uh propose it would remove
it i think the annual
um check over if you like is
very good idea uh i would ex i would say
we shouldn't accept this as a precedent
uh for anybody else because
if any other boats do come in and we do
ask for a bond
i don't want them saying oh well you've
taken away from the fresh spring i want
it to be a bond
uh that we can put in place in future
years but i would propose it now
okay um christy um obviously being the
champ i'm going to keep interjecting
today and say i second
your proposal there and i'd like to
mention mr puddy what um a few years ago
mr buddy when he actually came in
with a planning coming into harbor i can
remember a conversation with saying
i didn't want to i personally didn't
want to see another rust bucket coming
into biddeford
now you sir and your team have
proved me totally wrong and i commend
you for all the work you've done
because you've done an absolutely
fantastic job and very proud to have you
in biddeford and
i think what the trusts have done and
what you continue to do for the area
is absolutely fantastic and i i also
commend torah for working with you very
closely as well
it's nice that you know in partnership
it's turned out really good
for us all so i like the second that mr
puddy you had your hand up there
yeah i did and what i wanted to say is
yes
to uh the fact that torridge has
supported us both in kind and in in
in funds and we are hugely appreciative
of the support we've had
in the last five years one of the things
we had
originally undertaken to do and indeed
do do
is we conduct an annual survey of the
vessel
and the report goes to
to the local authority we've just had a
fairly expensive dry docking at
highland and wolf in appledore which
we're delighted to be able to do in the
sense of supporting this new company
and the ship was fully surveyed at that
point by
jeff wilson of pearson co who you know
um and his report will be forwarded to
the
uh harbour committee to to give them
assurance that the
vessel is very safe to remain in the
port
the other thing we undertook when we
came to biddeford was to dry dock the
ship within five to six years
um our five years are not up until
october of this year so we're well
within the scope of what we plan to do
and i thank councillor mcgoff for the
support and the
kind words he he's given to the trust
because
our aim is to make a difference in
biddeford and to support
extensively the maritime history of the
area
thank you very much buddy um james yeah
uh well i know it's already proposed and
seconded so i just i'd say i fully
support it
um i'm happy with the paragraph in risk
management about
insurance and academic identity and also
in the recommendations about the
um you know that they will be keeping up
a report as
mr puddy has just said so whilst uh i
just don't say or support it and
and wish them well with it thank you
any more questions will we go to the
vote
no okay tom has been has been seconded
to the votes okay councillor christy
mr gibbs councillor james
councilman goff that's unanimous chair
hey lovely thank you
okay item 11 is the exclusion of the
public
so that the public be excluded from the
remainder of the meeting
as a likely disclose of exempt
information is defined as schedule 12a
of the local government act 1972 so
to members of the public mr buddy um i
want to say goodbye to you and the
members on
youtube as well thank you much your
attendance today but we will now vote to
go into part two for part two item
so i'll say good goodbye to all i have a
proposal please
i'm happy to propose second
council christie thank you i'll take the
vote councillor christie
mr gibbs councillor james
or